Orit Balicer Tsur,
thank you so much for joining me.
How are you?
Good, how are you?
Fantastic. It's 9:00 p.m.
It's after Shabbat dinner where you're at.
So first of all, thank you
for taking the time to do this so late.
And what you mentioned was that
this is the reality
of living between continents, right?
That's right, yeah.
I'm used to it by now.
Definitely. So, architect by profession,
then turning into
a product manager at Lyft.
Serial entrepreneur
with an acquisition behind you.
And now running a startup at stealth mode.
And while you can't share
too much about it,
I'd love to hear a little bit
about the insights that led you
towards this new endeavor.
But Orit, take me back
all the way to Bezalel.
Take me back
to your architecture days.
Like what was architecture all about,
because if you're looking
at your track record today,
it seems so bizarre to be on your resume.
Yeah, I know. It's really not
the usual way to do it.
Most of the product managers
or entrepreneurs come
from a different background,
but I wanted to be an architect
since I was, I think, 10.
My best friend's grandfather
was a very good architect
and I saw his work and I was,
"Okay. This is the profession
that I want to choose for myself
when I grow up."
What was it about architecture? Why?
I think one thing
was about creation, creativity.
The way that you just invent things
and then people use them.
And I think there was something holistic
about architecture.
It was a little bit of math,
a little bit of art,
a little bit of psychology.
And you just had everything in it
and it was very appealing to me.
And there was the thing about
it was a profession that had a name.
It was, what are you? I'm an architect.
It's very, it's ...
You can explain it.
You can understand,
you can grasp ...
when you are a kid
and when you are a grown up too.
Something that is easily explained
to your grandmother.
Much more difficult when you're running
a stealth startup, right?
Exactly. Exactly.
What is it exactly that you are doing.
I'm not sure if,
I mean, my parents know what I'm doing,
but they're not really
... understand fully what I'm doing
how my day to day look like.
And so, I went ahead
and I studied architecture
in Bezalel Jerusalem, Israel.
And I became an architect.
And I loved it.
If you would ask me
during my years at Bezalel
if I would ever change profession,
I would tell you,
"Hell no. No way."
I will be an architect.
That's the best profession in the world.
I still think that.
I mean, definitely in terms of,
what is architecture, the essence of it,
it's the most beautiful profession
in the whole world.
It's a little bit different, I think,
the day to day.
I mean, dealing with contractors
is not exactly what you were thinking about
when you were studying.
But still, a beautiful thing to do.
And what happened, eventually, was that
I was working as an architect
and I was teaching at Bezalel
after I graduated,
but I had this opportunity
to come and work for a startup
first one when I was still a student
I was employee number six in Kaltura,
which was, still is, an amazing company.
And it all started back then.
We were working from,
I would say the garage.
The garage was very nice.
Very well ...
But still, it's like it was building it
from the essentials
and it was an amazing experience.
And then when I was only an architect,
I had all these chances to go
and be a consultant to different startups.
And I said,
"Yeah, I like it."
I mean, I like doing it
so I'll do it after hours.
So I had a day job
and then a night job as a consultant.
One of the companies that I worked for
was Soluto, which back then had a product
that was built for,
I think almost two years,
and no even one user
saw the product back then.
Wow.
It sounds crazy today,
but the days were before the lean startup.
It wasn't so obvious
that you have to meet the users
in order to build a good product.
And so there was a great technology,
amazing team.
And I joined to start running
the alpha, the beta, and go out.
We went to TechCrunch Disrupt
and we won the first prize
at TechCrunch Disrupt.
At Soluto, I started as a consultant,
but what happened was that
the CEO asked me to stay a little longer
and be head of marketing, and I said,
"Okay. I will do that
for a couple of years
and then I'll go back
and be an architect."
Of course.
Unbelievable.
- And I'm still waiting.
No, I do have to say Orit,
because, the way that I'm thinking about
the architecture scene
and I'm thinking about the startup scene.
The startup scene is all about agile
and about trying new things.
And maybe back then,
back in the day in Kaltura and Soluto,
we still didn't have
the lean startup methodology
and it wasn't about move fast
and break things.
But today, it's very evident
that when you're running a startup,
and I'm sure that when you were running
your product at Lyft,
which we'll talk about very soon,
it's all about trying very quickly
things getting a lot of market validation.
When you're an architect,
when you're building an office space
or you're building a building,
it's like the most waterfall thing
you can do, right?
You lay out all the plans
and then you're committing
to a three year project
when, God forbid, something changes
I'm just assuming.
So, it's interesting
how you're relating the two things,
but you're not focusing
on the difference between them,
you're focusing on the beauty
behind each industry.
Definitely, and I think
Well, you said three years.
I think that's true in the States,
but in Israel, I think you are not
...
It's amazing.
I think one of the reasons why I went
and wanted to be an architect
was this notion of
thinking about something,
making it realized,
and then it's going to be there after you.
And that was an amazing thing
to think about, for me.
And with startups,
it's not exactly the same thing;
it's not going to be there after you.
It's, as you said,
like a very short cycle.
You're building something,
five years from now,
what you build is no longer
going to be there.
You have to keep reinventing everything.
But that has beauty of its own
in a way.
So I think architecture
and entrepreneurship and product,
it's very similar in the way
you think about
I have a concept,
I have an idea of how I'm going to make
people's life better.
And then I'm going to account
everything that I have to take
from all sides.
From financials
and from behavioral aspects
and delightfulness
and all sorts ... you think about.
And then I have to translate that
to a different language
that someone else have to go ahead
and execute.
So you have to do ...
So, both are very similar
in that kind of way,
but what's nice about building startups
is that you see the small dents
that you're making.
It's not going to be there for years,
people are not living in it,
but you're making this dent
and you see it immediately.
And ... it's pretty exciting
because you see it from scratch
coming real, it's kind of magic in a way.
And in larger companies,
what's amazing is seeing the data.
It's building something
and then you're putting it out there.
Millions of people are using it
the day after.
And then you're starting to see
the effect of it.
And the effect is amazing,
because if you are doing something
that has meaning,
then you automatically,
when you A/B test it,
you automatically see the difference.
You see it, it's just there.
That's a different-
Right. So, you have the privilege
of both running an early stage startup,
which also got acquired.
So you were saying how
you have this hypothesis, but really,
only to get to be able
to test this hypothesis, which really
is the essence of the company,
it can take a lot of time
and this is sort of the make or break moment.
And then you go on
and you're running a product
within Lyft.
And you're get to see ...
We have this hypothesis,
let's just roll something out
to do A/B testing,
and within the next day,
we can make some executive decisions
and hypothesize on how
this is going to grow.
Talk to me a little bit about this product
you were building at Lyft
and some of this process
that you went through
as a product manager,
perhaps even looking
at some of the lessons you learned
from your architecture days.
Sure. So actually I think, in a way,
the product I built for lift, actually,
I used some of the understanding
of how cities and people work,
how they behave.
Yeah, because the first product
I built for Lyft was around commute.
What I was doing at Lyft
was running shared ride experiences,
which is basically every new experience
or new product
that more than one rider is using.
And so ... one was focusing on commute
and was this idea around,
Okay so, for Lyft,
you're tapping a button
and you're getting a driver
and they take you to the place
that you need to go
which is amazing for a certain people
or for certain situations,
but if you are not making
like a lot of money,
you can't use ... commute.
So, I was trying to figure out
how we can make it cheaper
for people to ride every day.
How we can make it more, let's say,
how people can plan around it,
which was very important.
Trying to figure out what's important
for people who commute
is very different than
trying to figure out what is important
when you are going out for a date
or a ride to the airport.
-100%
And some of the values were around
how I can plan around it.
How I can know that I'm getting exactly,
or a very similar experience every day.
That was very important.
The behavioral aspect
was very important,
more than I imagined.
Apparently people prefer to get,
let's say, a less super experience
in terms of like how long they are riding,
which I think is,
in a way, counterintuitive,
but they would rather ride longer
but if they're riding the same way,
they know exactly how long
it's going to take.
And they're taking the ride
from the same spot
and getting to the same spot.
Sometimes meeting the same people
on the way and riding with them.
That's more important
than getting there the fastest ...
Apparently people prefer to know
that they are going to be at the office
at 9 a.m. rather than like sometimes,
at 8:30 and sometimes at 9:30.
And so, we designed a product
according to that, those insights
that we got from people.
But Orit, how do you get those insights?
Is this solely based on analytics
and you're watching
how hundreds of thousands of people
are interacting with your product
and whether what is the churn rate
and what they're focusing on?
Or do you actually have to go
and speak to them personally?
How does it even work?
So, that's the nice thing
about a big company.
When you're in a very large company
with a very large user base,
you can do both.
And the thing about asking questions
are you have to ask the right questions.
And you don't know how to ask
the right questions
and then try to figure it out with data
if you don't have a hypothesis.
So, to get that hypothesis,
you have to have good intuition, I think,
and a lot of empathy to your users.
And you have to speak with them.
So I would say the process, in a way,
in the beginning,
is more similar to building a startup ...
First you have to talk face to face
with people who experience it who,
and you have to ask the right questions.
You don't want to influence them.
You don't want to have these ideas
that you're having ...
in their minds.
You have to get the real problems,
the real pains, figure them out,
and then try to solve them.
And once you do that, you can try
and ask the questions with data.
You can try and figure out
if you are right or wrong.
And usually the right way you do it
is not go ahead
and build this huge product
that is containing everything
you had in mind
and have this amazing experience
end to end all figured out,
because you're probably
going to be wrong about at least some of it.
And then, the way I think about it is,
you have to break your assumptions
to little pieces
and try the leanest way
to figure each one out with data.
And once you have that
and have you know,
you can start to build
your bigger vision
and transform it into a product.
Again, something very, very different
from when you're designing a building
that is meant to bring a delight
to the customers.
And there, you can't really just build
like one room and then say,
"Hey, do you like this?"
Maybe you can, I don't know.
Maybe it's sophisticated enough.
But it sounds like especially
when you're running a startup
or product manager at Lyft,
you were able to take these
very small chunks of hypotheses
and implement them in small scenarios
and test them out.
But I want to talk a little bit
about the insights that are leading now
towards your next venture,
which hopefully by the time this airs,
we'll know a little bit about.
What are those insights?
What got you really excited
into this idea of the future of workforce?
So I think one of the reasons
I was starting to be kind of obsessed
with this problem space was,
I was naturally taking Lyfts every day,
twice a day, at least.
And I was talking to the drivers
all the time.
Sometimes it was part of the work.
Most of the time, just because
I liked talking with people.
And then, I tried to figure out
what's bothering them.
Why are they doing it?
And I felt very fortunate to work
for a ride sharing company,
because I felt it gives the drivers
this opportunity to make a living
when sometimes they can't.
Many of the people had those situations
where they were unemployed
and or between jobs or moving between
one geography to another
or waiting to get their certificate.
And so being able to ... them.
So, I think that opportunity they had
to be able to just get in the car
and start earning money
so they won't lose everything
was really important.
To me, it was a great mission,
a great crowd to work for.
But then underneath that big mission
and that opportunity,
lies a lot of problems
that are unsolved yet
just with ride sharing.
So talking with them,
I thought that sometimes
they don't want to do it
because maybe they don't have a prospect.
They can't see how
they're going to have to progress
or have to learn something new
or to have a career path
or possibly do just between some parts,
between jobs.
And then other problems
were that they were thinking
they can make a living,
but not all drivers can make a living
out of ride sharing.
It's just the nature
of how those marketplaces work is
that they have peak hours and downtimes,
and some drivers
can really optimize their time
and sometimes they are very lucky
and they can get enough rides,
but if they're not at the right place
at the right times,
they just don't get rides
and they can't make a living ...
just driving.
Well, statistically,
more than 80% of the drivers
are working on more than one platform
because of that.
Really? Okay.
Yeah, it's crazy,
but that's the number.
And so I was thinking
how can I make those people's life better?
How can I provide them
with everything that is lacking,
and how can I build a product
that will suite them?
And that's how I started Overall,
which is still in stealth mode.
So, unfortunately I'm not going
to talk a lot about what it is exactly,
but stay tuned.
I love it. I love it.
Well Orit, best of luck with Overall.
Just in two in two sentences,
give me a little bit of taste
as to what Keeprz was
and a little bit about
being a first time entrepreneur running
You've joined
early stage companies before,
but now you're running
your own company,
you're one of the co-founders.
You get to the acquisition.
What are some of the key moments
in that journey
that you're gonna take with you
into your next venture?
So, there are several.
And I think, and looking at that,
it's not just Keeprz,
it's I think it's kind of a thing
that was built throughout my career
and you can kind of connect the dots.
So, Keeprz was an amazing experience.
It was the first time I'm an entrepreneur.
I saw how it was done
by other great enterprise
I work with and ... done it before.
And I think one of the amazing things
that I discovered was
that I can be jack of all trades.
I can do everything.
I was designing the screenings
with illustrator skills
that I had from Bezalel.
And I was building the experiences
and I was marketing
and analyzing the data we had
and interviewing potential clients.
And I just had to do all of it
and be good, good enough,
let's say, with everything.
And then, when I got to Lyft,
I figured that kind of skill
is not required anymore.
I didn't have to do everything anymore.
Actually, I wasn't supposed
it wasn't a good idea
to do everything by myself.
Lyft had amazing engineers
and data scientists and great designers,
and then I had to figure out well, then
what is my role here.
Right.
And I think my main lesson was
I have to take those amazing people
and make sure that the good ideas
that I'm having are resonating with them.
Everyone knows what direction
they have to run.
And then run the fastest they can
to ...
And taking that lesson with me,
actually I think it's pretty much
I take it now to my new startup
even though it's just starting.
And it's not ...
I still have to be jack of all trades,
but building the team
means I have to think about
what kind of team I'm building,
what kind of culture,
a culture which puts those people
in the center of things
and being aligned and working together
and bringing A type people.
10X engineers, 10X designers,
because once you have
those amazing people,
you just have to lead the way
and everything kind of happens the right way.
Orit, thank you again
for being so generous with your time
and for all the insight.
This was wonderful.
Before we leave, I need three words
that you would use to describe yourself.
Okay. So, I would say
creative or creating.
That's the one thing that's important for me.
That's why I'm waking up in the morning.
The other word I would say
would be doubt.
I'm doubting ...
I don't take anything for granted.
I try to check, I try to figure out
if the assumptions are right.
I think that would be the second one.
The third one would probably be family.
I love it.
The one most important thing
in my life.
100% and I'm sure it's gonna be
an interesting ride going through now
an early stage startup
still in stealth mode with the family.
But best of luck
and I can't wait to see more
about Overall,
and thank you again
for being so generous with your time.
It's really great.
Thank you for having me.
Take care.